Hey,
what's going on?
It's bill burr and it's time for the Monday morning podcast on Monday,
October 17th,
2016 what's going on?
How I yeah.
Oh,
are you,
oh look at you.
Um,
I am in Washington DC and uh,
I am doing,
I got three more shows here before I fly to Nashville and then I uh,
take my next special and um,
I think I'm ready to go Saturday night.
I was ready to kill myself after the,
after the show I did cause I was just,
even though it's showing great people had a good time,
I was just in my head the whole time going and then I'm going to do this joke
and then I will do this one and then that will flow into,
there's one I was in fucking,
I was fighting like I just was in my head.
And uh,
last night I was just like,
you know what?
Fuck it.
Just go up and whatever job feels like it wants to come out and do it that way.
That's the way you always do it.
Just do it that way.
All right.
How many fucking times do you have to learn this God damn lesson.
You're not the person that writes it all out and just stands up there with the
one hand in his pocket and the other one,
you know,
fucking making gestures.
It's not a way.
I'm a fucking,
I dunno.
I,
I got to walk around.
I got to get out there and walk around.
Um,
so I hope that isn't too loud.
I'm a turn this down a little bit.
Turned down the levels.
I didn't bring any of my recording shit cause I'm so fucking psycho focus for
this thing right now.
Um,
so I dunno.
Like you know what's weird is I'm going to do this special right before the
biggest fucking election of my lifetime,
considering these are the two worst goddamn candidates and I'm really trying to
see a light at the end of the fucking tunnel.
But what's weird is,
you know,
by the time my shit comes out,
the election's going to be over.
And you know how it is when the election's over,
whoever lost within three days.
I mean,
it's like boy band fame.
You'd just gone like,
remember,
remember how quickly Al Gore disappeared?
He just fucking disappeared.
And then like in a month later,
he had like this mountain man beard,
like whatever,
whatever fucking happened to that guy.
Um,
you know,
I'll tell you what else was fucked up.
You know what they were bitching about Hillary.
And there was saying like,
why is the media so silent because Al Gore got accused of sexual assault.
Why aren't they saying anything?
And it's just like,
I love how all you,
if you just get fucking accused of it,
you know,
there's all this shit on the side.
They protect women where it's like don't give up their identities and all of
that,
which I completely agree with and I fucking hate Al Gore,
but he,
he was just,
anybody can just say,
this guy did this shit to me and then all of a sudden it's,
it's all over.
Okay.
The media and
I dunno,
I,
I saw something recently,
the fuck story was it?
Oh,
there's a movie coming out that beast of a nation.
Okay.
And the guy who directed it got accused and got acquitted.
Of Rape.
And everybody's going like,
you know,
well,
what's the,
what's the deal?
He is like,
well,
he went on trial and they said he was innocent.
You know what I mean?
But people that will follow that person for the rest of their life.
So my thing is,
okay,
if you get accused of that shit in the public,
you're,
you're never innocent.
So,
okay,
that guy got accused.
He got acquitted,
okay.
They said he was innocent of the crime,
you know,
and,
but because everybody knows his fucking name,
you know,
20 goddamn years later,
it's still coming up and tainting of,
uh,
whatever he's doing in his life.
So then it becomes,
well,
I hope he fucking did it because he's getting treated as though he did.
Does that make any fucking sense whatsoever?
You know what I mean?
And there'll be some,
you know,
actually,
it doesn't mean that he was innocent.
It just means that there wasn't enough evidence to convict.
Um,
which is yet another thing.
But I gotta tell you it like
the one I will say,
and I know he's just been accused his fucking Donald Trump right?
When a bunch of broads came out and said,
oh,
he did this,
he did that,
Yada,
Yada.
The Clintons are so fucking filthy.
I mean,
yeah,
I just like,
well,
who knows that this is fucking true,
right?
Like it should,
this is just coming out now.
This guy has been fucking running for office for over a year and a half and it's
just coming out now.
So I took it all with a grain of salt because politics of fucking filthy and no
one's more filthy than the fucking Clintons.
Right.
But one woman finally comes on,
I was riding with the lovely Nia and we're in the car and she goes to tell her
story and rather than it being the usual generic,
and then he did this and he did that and I felt uncomfortable.
And people are like,
what the fuck?
She goes,
whatever.
She's poor woman's like in her twenties,
and then this fucking old creep is coming at her with his orange fucking hair.
Right.
Which I guess that's kind of self hatred there,
but I mean,
at least mine's real.
Um,
and when he makes a move on her,
she pushes him away and she goes,
I said,
get real.
And then she goes,
he then pushed his genitals in like toward thrusted his genitals towards me when
get real me.
They were like,
oh my God,
that definitely happened.
That's just too,
it's just too fucking specific.
So I'm being a little hypocritical here because the person wasn't put on trial.
But,
um,
but anyways,
this is what the fuck I wanted to talk about.
Um,
I gotta do my special this week and you know something I don't give a fuck.
Cause people are always like,
well the standup special,
it should be timeless.
It should be timeless.
It's like,
let me ask you this.
I mean,
and I'm not putting myself obviously in the same category.
Do you give a fuck?
You know,
if you listen to an old Kinison thing and he's talking about,
you know,
who those fucking idiots trying to put like warning labels on albums,
does it matter that it then,
or like you listen to a Richard Pryor and he's talking about Muhammad Ali and
shit.
Like,
I don't,
I don't mind that a dates itself.
Fuck it.
Cause I know what it felt like Saturday night when I was just like,
do not talk about that shit.
By the time this special comes up that stuff will already be gone.
I don't give a fuck.
I'm going to talk about it.
And um,
it seems dated when we're editing.
That's what the fuck I'll do.
I hope this isn't boring to you to take you through the my new show of doing a
standup special.
But anyways,
I'm having a great time here in,
I'm in DC.
I went over to Georgetown yesterday.
I just sort of walk the city a little bit with a Joe Barden neck,
which was awesome because this is one of the most confusing fucking cities is
far as like,
you know,
trying to figure out basically where you're at.
Like there was three areas of this city that I was familiar with,
but I didn't know how they connected.
There was the DC Improv,
there was the w hotel near the White House where I've stayed a number of times.
Um,
and now there's like the National Theatre and where I'm staying this time.
And,
uh,
the thing about DC is it's all like,
you know,
the address is like,
whatever,
six,
five,
nine Pennsylvania Avenue,
but then it's like southwest,
northwest fucking east or whatever.
And that's just like,
how the fuck do,
I mean you need like a Goddamn compass.
Just the way this whole thing is laid out.
So,
uh,
yesterday I actually did a fucking walk and I kind of walk to all three of those
places and like,
I didn't realize I'm at the national theater.
I'm like,
I wonder where the w and the White House's compared to that.
And I was like,
fucking two blocks over.
And then like another two blocks in about six blocks up was the Improv.
So I feel like I have that little corridor all la memorized.
And,
um,
I finally flew into fucking Reagan airport.
Okay.
You know,
rather than flying out to fucking Dallas,
which is like 30 miles,
I think west of the city is some shit like that north.
I don't know what the fuck it is.
So I land and I check a bag,
which I never do.
I never fucking check a bag.
Like when I went to Europe for like a month,
touring took a quick vacation.
Um,
I had a little fucking overhead compartment bag and you know something,
it was fine.
Oh,
hang on a second.
My breakfast is here.
All right,
I'm back.
Um,
what guy was hilarious guy delivering the food.
I was like,
Hey,
what's up?
And he was just like,
hey,
where are you aiming to point?
Uh,
over there on the table.
Be Fine.
Okay.
And you are your breakfast.
Real weird voice.
Um,
anyways,
at a terrorist beard too,
you know,
pre nine 11,
I would call it an Abe Lincoln beards.
You know,
he just got the beard and no mustache.
That was the Abe Lincoln.
The fucking Chin strap with the terrorist beard is the fucking no mustache.
Chinstrap but then it sort of frizzed out,
you know,
that's a terrorist spirit unless you're black.
If you're black,
that just means you from Philadelphia.
Okay.
Plowing ahead here.
Um,
the hell was I talking about?
Oh,
who gives a shit?
Was it even that importance?
Probably not.
Um,
anyways,
I had a great week,
uh,
before I came out here.
I had a really cool experience.
Um,
do you guys remember a couple of years ago I was raving about that John Fabro
movie.
Um,
uh,
chef the haven't seen the movie.
It's,
it's phenomenal.
It's just such a great,
great movie and uh,
and just don't be hungry when you watch it because you will,
you will consume like 12,000 calories after watching it because,
uh,
some of the food,
basically all of the food that they make looks unbelievable.
So long story short,
you know,
like whenever they have like end credit stuff on like a movie,
um,
you know,
it's usually like outtakes or something from the actress scrolling up or,
or,
or whatever.
Um,
John had to learn how to basically,
I guess,
you know,
they had a dad,
he had to take cooking classes and stuff,
so he looked like he was an actual chef.
So the,
the,
the movie movies character would ring true,
you know,
all that actory stuff.
So there was a guy showing them how to make a grilled cheese sandwich.
This guy,
a chef,
Roy Choi,
who,
uh,
had the Kogi truck started the whole food truck movement out here in la and
everything.
And um,
he was showing them how to do it and John just decided to film it when he,
when he,
when he was making this cheeseburger and it was like so fucking intense when the
guy was doing like all crunched down looking at it and he was moving the grilled
cheese grilled cheese sandwich.
You just thinking like,
this is something like a fucking 12 year old can make,
but watching this guy do it and the level of intensity,
the game seven fucking intensity that this guy had when he made it,
I was just like,
what?
It like blew me away.
It was like,
I've never been that into fucking cooking something ever.
You know,
I never seen it.
Right.
So a long story short,
um,
I don't know if I'm supposed to say this or anything.
I watched him give a shit.
This would be like a teaser,
but a fabulous been like filming some stuff.
Um,
of him cooking with this chef and
I ran into him out here when he said,
hey,
that guy,
you know,
who made the cheeseburger and I made the grilled cheese sandwich is going to be
out there.
You want to come out and watch him make it?
And I was like,
yeah,
fucking absolutely.
I would love to.
So I was hanging off set and I got to watch them make it and everything.
And uh,
they pulled me in,
let me fucking make the grilled cheese sandwich with them.
It was one of the coolest,
most surreal things I've done in this business.
And I'm,
the fucking grilled cheese sandwich was so good,
like an idiot.
I'm out here on the road and they had a grilled cheese sandwich on the room,
service of a fucking hotel and I order it like it's going to be as good.
And uh,
and it wasn't,
um,
it sounds out I learned that fucking lesson,
but a,
I want to thank him and uh,
chef Roy for letting me hang out.
I had a such a fucking great time.
Um,
I learned so much shit about cooking.
And,
and what was funny was he never,
he never went like,
oh,
this is how you do this,
this,
that.
You just kind of went in there and did it.
And what amazed me was afterwards when I was thinking about all the stuff that I
saw him do,
like,
um,
just how you would just like move the grilled cheese sandwich around how he
would,
you know,
fuck with the temperature.
I mean,
I was like a fucking,
I'm a robot when I cook.
I'm literally like,
you know,
whatever,
quarter tablespoon of salt.
And I like take out it out and I measure it and flick the top.
Like these guys,
none of,
they don't use any sort of measuring whatsoever.
They're constantly tasting the ship and uh,
and then adjusting that temperature off.
But whatever my temperature is,
act,
that was,
that's what the fuck we're cooking at,
which makes no sense
when you really think about it.
But I was just like,
it's like being completely locked in on,
on your rack as opposed to just out there kind of flowing with it.
And,
um,
what is funny,
so they would teach me now you've got to taste it as you're going,
you know,
so I was doing that and uh,
John mentioned,
he goes,
yeah,
when you cook like this,
it tastes great,
but by the time you're done,
he goes,
you don't want to eat it because you've tried it so many times.
You were actually kind of full a little bit.
And that was kind of,
that was kind of the deal with everything except for the grilled cheese
sandwich.
Um,
made a Cuban sandwich.
It was,
it was crazy.
The whole thing was crazy.
So,
um,
so that happened.
And A,
I'm recording this shit on garage band and as always,
I have no idea how much time has gone by.
I should have just looked at the clock up top,
but I didn't.
But this is the new me.
This is the new calmer me who refuses to let technology piss him off.
Do you know I spent an hour and a half the opening night Bruins,
um,
there opening night there,
first fucking game.
Who the fuck did they play?
They play Toronto Saturday.
I don't even remember.
But since like 2007 2008 I have been,
you know,
I've had the center ice package and I've had an account online and I'm able to
just sign in and watch the fucking games.
Lo and behold this year I can't,
so I don't flip out.
I call up,
I spent an hour and a fucking half talking to people from Malaysia.
Okay.
Cause I finally got one woman to tell me where she was at,
cause this first guy was going like,
he,
you know,
he's just talking to me and I'm like,
yeah,
I want to watch the hockey.
And he's like hockey.
I'm like,
yes,
hockey.
He goes,
just like ice hockey.
I'm like,
yeah,
Bruins original six,
2011 Stanley Cup champions.
And I was like,
don't flip up.
And finally I was on the phone with this guy for like 45 minutes.
He couldn't figure it out,
what the fucking problem was.
And I got a little heated.
I was just like,
dude,
you know,
I'm not trying to be a jerk,
but there's a little bit of a language barrier here.
And you didn't know what hockey was to start with.
I should have considered that as an omen.
I,
we're 45 minutes and if we haven't figured it out yet like this,
this isn't working out.
Okay,
have a nice evening.
And he said,
okay,
I'm sorry.
And then I felt bad and then I just fucking hung up.
And then I called back and then I got another person and that and she's going
like hockey,
like ice hockey,
right?
Same fucking thing.
And I was saying,
well this is the problem I'm having.
It's like I'm literally trying to watch something that the person on the other
side of the phone doesn't know what it is and they're on the other side of the
world.
I go like,
where are you right now?
And she goes,
Asia,
I go,
you were in Asia.
And she goes,
yes.
She goes,
I hope that's not going to be a problem.
Which made me feel like a Trump supporter.
I was like,
no,
it's not a prom.
But you know what I mean?
I go,
you know,
if he would try to watch cricket and you had to call me up and like cricket,
like the insect or the sport once you get frustrated.
So long story short,
I spent an hour and a half,
I spent like half the fucking game on the phone and they still couldn't figure
it out.
And I just said,
you know what,
to hell with it.
And I felt my wife watching me and then she kept coming in and then she was
trying to like get upset for me,
you know,
cause she didn't want to see the time bomb go off.
And uh,
I actually held it together and I didn't get to see one second of the game.
I guess they have some new thing this year.
You can no longer stream it.
You have to pay for for both now.
I Dunno,
they got a t and t bought them.
So now you have to pay for both because that's how corporations,
yeah,
to make like a zillion dollars.
They not,
and they now have to make fucking,
okay,
I got to make,
you know,
two zone of dollars.
It's just like,
why can't you constant just be happy.
Okay.
With the 70 foot yacht,
why do you always have to be run 94?
Yeah.
Fucking unbelievable.
Then it just a,
I don't know,
you know,
it's,
listen to your fucking,
I'm gonna Start Moving this computer cause I know it gets really loud when I do
it.
Sorry.
Um,
I was listening to NPR,
right?
Well my wife was listening to it and I was tolerating it.
I like some of the fucking music,
but just like their politics.
It's just,
it's,
it's so,
it's so childlike to just be sitting there leaning all the way to one fucking
side.
It's just like,
really nobody with a blue tie does anything wrong.
Everybody with a red tie is an asshole.
It's almost,
it's like fucking political,
like racism in a way.
Um,
but everybody thinks that they're a fucking safe,
you know,
one of the dumbest things ever.
And those Trump rallies,
like there's somebody had like a sign or a tee shirt that says,
fuck your feelings.
I love how people on the right just think there's so fucking like hardcore and
like,
you know,
people can't handle the truth.
You know what I mean?
You know what they're like people on the right that I liked that they liked
those,
you know,
like you haven't made some chicken.
She'll just say some shit.
Like,
you know,
guys are intimidated by me.
You know,
they can't,
they can't handle me.
You know?
And then,
you know,
joke I used to do my act as like,
hey,
you ever think maybe get just content.
You know?
I mean that's,
I'm not saying you are,
but that's definitely a possibility,
you know,
that could be behind door number three and that could be the fucking answer,
you know?
Yes.
Self-Involved shithead.
I just,
I don't know.
Wow.
And then like people on the left,
I remember one time I was doing it,
I was doing them,
I had a small part in a movie and we were shooting in New Orleans and at our
hotel,
like this big Republican convention was coming.
So they had this big banner,
it was all in red.
So one of the producers on,
on the,
uh,
on the movie was just so,
she was just like,
oh my God,
did you see that banner?
I was just like,
Jesus am I in like where am I right now?
And I just looked at us like,
you know,
people are allowed to be Republicans.
She just goes,
oh,
I know.
No,
I'm just being that person and blend that I think to fucking drive me up the
wall.
Well,
cheap bill,
aren't you just the perfect fucking person?
I'm a yeah,
you know what I am,
I'm a fucking conspiracy theorist.
And once you become that,
you know,
you lose a lot of friends,
you drive people nuts,
but you start trying to look behind whatever the fuck they showed you.
And like I don't think it fucking matters which person when's this?
Because
you know the people on the other side,
because they make in your fucking pay for the,
the,
the center ice package on TV and now on cable they got negative,
an extra revenue stream.
This selling all your fucking inflammation and they've got all this money,
they money on both horses.
So it doesn't fucking matter.
So I'm listening to NPR with my wife and they just sort of casually mentioned
that scientists said the Great Barrier Reef is now dead.
And you know what they segwayed into after that?
Uh,
the results of the Dodgers game.
So,
um,
I don't know.
I just think below it were completely fucked and I want to thank whoever created
the Great Barrier Reef.
I'm sorry.
We finally wrapped it around a fucking tree.
That's what we're like.
We're like a bunch of fucking rich kids in our,
and our,
our parents bought us this beautiful fucking car and we're just out there doing
neutral drops and fucking slamming it into trees and a,
we're going to fuck the whole thing up,
you know?
But unlike rich kids' parents,
I don't think Mommy's gonna get us another car.
Do you know when I was in fucking high school and there was these two kids,
right?
These two rich kids,
one of them got a fucking Pontiac Trans am
like a brand new one.
The F body,
you know,
the one that everybody fucking loved in the 80s,
the night rider version.
He got the fucking trans and this kid was like a 1617 year old kid.
He had a brand new like 19 whatever,
85 86 trans-am.
So the other rich kids,
parents,
they're like competing.
But this other kid,
a fucking 1985 or 1986 IROC Z,
I mean they were pulling up to this school,
their car was worth twice what their teacher's car was worth.
I remember there was this teacher,
a foreign language teacher,
and he had this giant boat from the early seventies and the fucking,
the door lock was like the door wouldn't close.
And to this day there's no excuse for this guy.
Now I could just get in the fucking door,
close up,
fixed.
He fucking tied like a quarter inch rope around like the handle of the door and
then like 15 times around his head rest and he'd have to get out the fucking
passenger side.
And I'm one of the great things about getting old is you stop giving a fuck
about what people think about you.
But um,
for the most part that's a great thing.
But in that instance,
that was not a good thing.
That was not a good thing for people to see because being a teacher as a
tremendous,
tremendous profession,
but,
um,
you can't show up in a piss yellow fucking
both that you got the fucking door tied to the head rest.
I mean,
as much as you love something,
you want to be able to support a fucking family.
I always stopped looking at that.
Looking back years later that there might've been a half dozen people that were
considering being a teacher myself,
one of them.
And once you saw that,
you were like,
yeah,
you know what?
I don't think I want to do that.
I want to walk around with a dirty sport code having to get out of the passenger
side of my fucking car,
cause I can't even afford to get the God damn door lock fixed.
You dropped like three of the four years I was in high school.
This guy would pull up in that fucking car.
Um,
so anyways,
these two kids got the these cars and um,
okay,
so of course you're driving around like maniacs.
Of course everybody's drinking and driving.
This was the 80s.
This was like a,
this is,
you know,
this was some sort of a,
I dunno,
it was an activity that was done.
You went out,
you found somewhat of age to buy a case of beer and then you just drove around
town.
There was nothing to do.
You drove around town and tried to run into other kids you went to your high
school with and they would be driving around,
you know,
with the 12 pack in their car.
And he'd be like,
where you go?
And then you'd find some dead end street and you all go down there and then the
cops would come down and break it up and you drive around.
Everybody would gather someplace else.
It was weird.
There was no cell phones and somehow everybody figured out where the hell
everyone was going.
Um,
so long story short,
the kid who had the treads and ended up fucking
okay,
you don't go into fast,
pushed it past the limit and uh,
went flying into a bunch of trees.
Fortunately it was smaller trees,
so the trees lost the battle.
But he totaled his fucking car.
That was right as we were graduating.
So you know what his parents did to teach them a lesson?
They went out and they bought him a corvette.
So is the thing now he's got the corvette,
he fucked up.
He totaled his car.
They went out,
not only bought him a brand new car,
they bought them an even better car.
He had a corvette.
So now the other kid who didn't fuck up his car is now looking at is Iraq.
Like it's a piece of shit.
So within three months he then had a corvette and beyond,
you know,
so you could one up the other kid,
he um,
he had a custom interior.
He had like all this would put on the inside of it because the,
uh,
the eighties Corvettes,
the interior was unbelievably plane.
And um,
and that was the last day was saw of either one of them.
Cause then I graduate except for the kid who got the custom corvette.
Hey,
I ran into a bar,
ran into him in a bar about two years ago.
Okay.
And,
um,
he was hammered and proceeded to say some of the most racist Shit I've ever
heard in my life.
And I just sort of slowly back the way,
like,
all right buddy,
see it another 30 years.
Um,
anyways,
let's read some advertising here at this point.
Let me see if I can find where the fuck I'm at.
I'm an idiot.
I didn't put the fucking advertising it.
Now you have to listen to all of these clickings I apologize.
Sorry.
One last click and wait.
All right.
Oh Jesus.
Look who's here.
It's sorry.
It's our,
it's our favorite.
[inaudible] I'll walk me undies.
Me.
Andy.
Who the fuck are you gonna vote for?
But do do doot me undies.
Mandy's the fucking dope or the whore.
I don't know who you're going to vote for,
but I know they both should be seeing the door cause they both suck.
One's kind of a,
the other is a fucking grip.
I don't know.
None of it's funny to me anymore.
Um,
can you imagine if Hillary Clinton,
Fuck Dick Cheney.
Could you imagine what fucking what?
What would that baby,
the capabilities of that baby.
You know what I mean?
I think that that baby would be the last person on earth with all the fucking AI
robots and even the AI robots would be like,
yeah,
we're not fucking with that one.
All right.
I think we took this Westworld thing far enough,
but this one here,
we'll just,
you know,
we'll keep an eye on it.
There's no other human for this thing to breed with.
We'll just let it slowly die out
and uh,
you know what I mean?
Just sorta,
just leave it the fuck alone.
All right.
Me,
Andy's,
everybody.
A picture.
A world where putting on a new pair of underwear isn't just fresh.
You're stepping into a better day.
Think about it.
Underwear is the first thing you put on and the last thing you take off.
Why would you settle for anything less than the best feeling underwear on the
planet?
Um,
you,
Andy's focuses solely on producing the most comfortable underwear you've ever
experienced.
I can't even tell you what I just fucking picture there.
I just pictured a bunch of people standing there as these me undies people had
like,
you know,
you know what a maxi pad is shaped like,
but it's made out of that modal modal,
you know,
and they just fucking slapping it on everybody's under carriage and then they
just look at the look of bliss or fucking discomfort on their face.
But like,
Nah,
it's not soft enough yet.
Sorry.
I've been watching a lot of shit about robots.
So the whole human thing is starting to fucking float away here.
All right.
Uh,
my friends at me undies sent me a few pairs a while back and now I can't imagine
wearing anything else.
Of course I can.
I can imagine wearing fucking anything,
a human face.
You know,
I've watched Hannibal Lecter,
um,
it really makes each day that much better.
They sent me two pairs.
One was actually my size and the other one was the Greg Louganis cut,
uh,
which I wore one time and my wife almost passed out.
She laughed so hard,
um,
just picture me standing and there was sort of pinkish red and they were
unbelievably tight.
And,
uh,
I was not in good shape,
so my fucking,
my pasty fucking stomach was and,
and love handles.
What kind of hanging over the top.
Oh,
there's a fucking image for you.
Take that one to lunch.
All right.
For the price of two cocktails,
Mandy's,
we'll deliver you deliver your new favorite pair of underwear right to your
doorstep.
Better Day guaranteed.
Try them on.
And if they aren't the most comfortable,
best feeling undies you've ever had,
they're a fund you and you,
they let you keep your first pair for free.
Uh,
included in the price is the sweet touch of modal,
creepy,
a special fabric made with the best in class raw materials that are
scientifically proven to be three times softer than cotton.
These Uber Cozy undies get real.
But Trump was me.
Undies are sold exclusively on the [inaudible] website where you will enjoy free
shipping and the U S and Canada.
Uh,
and for a limited time,
everyone in my audience gets 20% off their first order,
but you have to go to our special URL,
[inaudible] dot com slash bar with the these better day guarantee.
You have nothing to lose,
so don't wait any longer.
Go to [inaudible] dot com slash bar right now for 20% off your first order.
That's [inaudible] dot com slash bar ah right.
Oh,
Jay's is.
It's Jolly Shave Club.
Don't do fucking Tom Grady's back kid.
Dude.
If to fucking buffalo bills.
Hadn't beat a fucking 20th string quarterback.
We might've gone fucking undefeated in the regular season.
Again,
kid dollar shave club guys,
um,
you know,
to go to dollar shave club for a fantastic shape.
Uh,
what you probably don't know is that they have other amazing products to the
quality is the best on the market.
Their bodywash is great and won't dry out your skin.
They're pre and post shave stuff.
Keeps your skin soft and smooth.
There's stuff we'll have you looking and smelling like 1 million bucks.
Do all his shave club got stuff they got stuff for your hair,
for your face,
for your underpants,
for everywhere to keep you feeling and looking fresh.
Once you're in the club,
you'll see they've got the best grooming products out there and they're all a
floor affordable.
This is really starting to feel like a cult.
Might been the time I almost accidentally joined fork could Scientology.
Ah,
right.
Now's your chance.
I didn't almost join it.
I just didn't realize what it was.
You know,
I thought it was an acting class.
It wasn't acting class,
but it was run by Scientology and they were all like,
we have our own parking,
we have our own security.
I literally said in,
I go,
Jesus Christ,
I feel like I'm joining a cult.
And the guy's eyes did something weird and he was trying to figure out if I was
being a wise ass or if I was fucking around.
And then once I figured out what it was,
I blew them off.
And then they kept calling me and I finally fucking picked up and it was like,
did we lose you?
It's like,
yeah,
you did.
All right.
Right now.
Right now's your chance to see for yourself why so many people love dollar shave
club.
If you're not a member a yet and you've never joined,
now's the time you get your first month of razors for free.
Just just pay the shipping and it's only a few bucks.
Join today.
Go to dollar shave club.com/bird that's dollar shave club.com/bar did I ever
tell you guys a Scientology story?
I read the other advertising later.
This is more interesting.
All right.
So,
um,
this is like fucking,
I don't know how many years ago this is.
Bill Clinton was still in office,
I think when this happened.
And um,
okay.
Basically I need to take an acting class.
I'm living in Los Angeles
and I needed to take an acting class,
right?
So,
uh,
you know,
whatever.
So somebody suggested this fucking place and I went over there.
It was a Beverly hills play house,
which the name of this fucking place.
And I went over there and I show up for the act of class and the teacher goes,
this is so fucking weird.
He just goes,
oh,
it's big.
Class was packed.
And it was a well known actor too.
So I was like,
wow,
man,
this is going to be a fucking great class.
And it was,
it was a great class other than the fucking creepy vibe.
So to start the class,
the guy goes,
okay,
does anybody have any news they want to share with the class?
Hmm.
All right.
So people raise their hands and basically it was actors talking about what they
booked that week.
And um,
you know,
and there's a thing I guess,
amongst actors as you're starting out,
you get envious and you get jealous.
So I guess this was a reaction to this,
what this is,
this whole exercise is about people put their hands up,
this is like,
you know,
fucking the mid nineties or some shit.
And so it'd be like,
yeah,
I just booked,
I booked a guest star on,
on,
uh,
on friends and,
and then the whole class like ridiculously loud and forever [inaudible] amount
of time we'll just go woo woo.
Like clapping and screaming.
Like somebody just cured cancer
and then it all died down.
It was just like,
what the fuck was that?
And then somebody else goes,
oh yeah,
hey,
I just,
uh,
you know,
I just booked a reoccurring on union square.
If it crazy.
So then what's,
that shit dies down.
I was immediately like,
Hey man,
I knew la was a little different,
but what the fuck is this?
They go a,
Hey,
we've got a couple of new students here auditing the class.
Uh,
he just moved here from New York City,
please welcome bill Burke.
And they,
they,
they clapped and cheered just as loud as they did for the other people that book
like friends.
But here's the thing,
when they were cheering,
no one was looking at anyone.
Okay.
It would just sort of staring straight ahead,
clapping and screaming as loud as you possibly could.
And I remember like my face turn red,
like I got embarrassing.
What the fuck?
And then that's when I,
I,
um,
you know,
after the class we took the first break and the,
the,
the act or teaching the class and the actors were great,
you know,
other than the weird vibe,
right?
So I fucking go up there and the other guy goes,
how are you doing?
And I looked at him,
he was like,
yeah,
doing good,
because he's a great actor.
He totally read me.
He goes,
uh,
he goes to the beginning of the class was,
um,
was that a little bit too much?
I was like,
ah,
yeah,
my,
it might've been
so I go on the back,
you know,
now they're going to try to get the money out of me.
Like every acting class does.
This is nothing against Scientology.
So that's when I sat down and that's when the guy was just like,
you know,
we're very,
um,
self sufficient.
We have our own security,
we have our own parking.
Everything was their own.
And that's when I said it said Jesus Christ,
you know,
I had just had to break the tension.
It was so fucking weird.
So I just made this joke,
you go,
Jesus Christ,
I feel like I'm joining a cult.
It was me and this other kid sitting.
I don't know what the Fuck I've happened to him.
I don't know if he's clear yet or he fucking move back to Iowa.
I have no idea what.
But um,
the guy made like this weird face when I said it.
And um,
so I left and I was like,
wow,
that was fucking weird.
But it was still still like,
it was a good class though,
you know,
and uh,
and I really liked acting class in that type of shit.
And so I was still kinda on the fence.
Okay.
And I ended up running into somebody,
uh,
later on that night I think at the laugh factory.
And I mentioned,
and the person who was like,
where were,
where was the class?
And I said,
it was a Beverly hills play house.
And he just goes,
built that Scientology,
you'll get the fuck out of here.
It's an active class.
They said,
no,
but it's,
yeah,
they're trying to recruit you into that religion.
So I've got all fucking weirded out.
And uh,
you know,
they just kept calling and leaving messages on my fucking answer machine.
And then that's,
you know,
finally they called again and I've been ducking them for like three days and
after three days I was just like,
no,
I thought they were watching me and shit.
I got all fucking paranoid.
Not saying they were,
but I just get,
you know,
I mean,
I'm a fucking conspiracy theorists.
Last thing I need is an actual cult fucking hounding me.
That was not good for my psyche.
So finally,
after three days,
they,
they called again and that's just,
I was like,
what am I am fucking bitch.
I can't just call these people up and say,
go fuck yourself.
So I just picked up the phone,
I'm like,
hello.
And they'll be like,
hey,
little Beverly hills play house.
I go,
yeah man,
I'm all set.
And the guy's like,
oh,
did we lose you?
I was like,
yeah,
you did.
All right.
Don't call me anymore.
He goes,
okay,
fine.
And then that was it.
They left me alone.
But that was,
I think it was,
cause it was early on,
you know,
so,
and I have to deal with Donald Sutherland.
Like when I walked out to my car later on that night,
just pointing at me like an invasion of the body snatchers.
Um,
you know,
not to say that Scientology is any more or less fucked up to my religion.
You know,
I've always maintained that at the inquisition was filmed like my,
um,
my religion wouldn't exist anymore.
That's what happened with the Nazis.
They filmed this shit,
so no one's ever gonna Forget it.
The shit that my religion did was never filmed.
So it's just like stick figures and drawings and not,
not cares.
You know what I mean?
But to actually have the actual footage of like,
Oh yes,
not only did it really happen,
this is what it looked like.
It's,
it's a fucking rap.
Um,
what am I talking about?
All right,
let's get back till fucking the subjects here.
I wanted to talk about instead of Scientology in,
in Holocaust footage,
um,
what,
what do we got here?
What did we get here?
Oh,
you know what?
I ain't even mention last,
I didn't even mention anything.
Congratulate the fucking Cleveland Indians for sweeping the red sox and um,
you know,
I'm wondering if I always pick on Dan Shaughnessy,
which,
you know,
to be fair isn't fair,
but for me to just single him out is,
is kind of funny.
So I'm going to just trashing him.
The fucking,
I'm,
I wonder if it did,
did Dan Shaughnessy or any of those other guys who demanded the Red Sox?
Make a change after we had that fucking collapse in 2012 was it 2012 we had the
collapse in September.
Well,
whatever the fuck,
I can't remember what the hell it was.
All I remember was,
however we got rid of Terry Francona was we had basically we,
you know,
we didn't win the world series.
We didn't win the playoffs.
So how many years in a row and then everybody demands of fucking change.
Like this guy who won two world series with us,
oh by the way,
we had one in 86 years suddenly does not know how to win a fucking championship
anymore.
So we fucking,
you know,
the sports writers demand to trade the ownership fucking gives into it or
whatever.
I mean,
I'm not saying they actually literally listen to these guys,
but like I just would love these sports writers that demanded the red sox make a
fucking move,
you know,
at least acknowledged the fact,
oh,
there's Terry Francona all these years later coming back and sweep it.
Irs,
you know,
the first round of the playoffs,
Theo Epstein,
it's running the cubs right now.
I don't know.
These are all like former red sox.
They all knew what the fuck they were doing.
Why did we get rid of all of these guys?
Theo Epstein is a fucking genius.
This guy's going to break the,
he already broke the curse of the baby.
Help do that.
Now he's going to break the curse to go right.
Automatic Hall of fame.
Jon lesters pitch and form.
It's like this whole post season is just littered with former fucking red sox,
which,
you know,
what do I care?
We want three.
Who gives a fuck?
We went three this decade.
Am I actually gonna Complain about that?
Oh,
I think I am.
No,
not really.
I don't give a fuck.
You know what it is?
I think it's safe to say I want to see a cubs Indians world series.
I mean,
I liked the Dodgers.
Um,
blue jays.
I don't mind,
although Getty Lee one time talk shit about the bug reds,
the red sox and their fans.
And ever since then I just hated Toronto Bluejay fans.
You know,
I blame him.
Getty,
Lee from rush,
the Bass player,
you know,
today,
he's Tom Sawyer's a mean mean.
Um,
yeah.
So I would love to see that both of them,
they're already doing like all this ever.
You know what's fucking sucks about being in a drought like the cubs are in like
ESPN or all these guys to just have to fucking sit there and just splice
together every fucking horrible thing that happened and they just try to make
it,
you know,
I got so sick of that as a red sox fan.
So I have,
I have a lot of empathy for cubs fans because they don't do it to the Indians as
much as the Indians tried it.
Fans try to act like they're long suffering Indian fans.
It's like,
dude,
you know,
it's 1948 you've suffered half his fucking law.
All right.
And then also nobody was eating,
and I even say it's about the cubs.
Nobody chance in 1908.
Yeah.
You know,
the way they chanted 1918 at five.
Was that a fucking devil rays game back when they were the devil race before
those dopes thought that sounded too evil.
Fucking Clearwater cons.
MMM.
They chanted in 1918 at us when I went,
I went to a game down at Tampa and they would chant.
I was just looking at [inaudible] you fucking serious.
Yeah.
We haven't won in [inaudible] 86 fucking years,
but we still got five more than you.
MMM.
They chanted that at,
at us.
I went to an inner league game if the old veterans stadium in Philadelphia,
and I'm like,
like these guys went over a hundred years.
They went from like 1880 something almost a hundred years to 1980 but they'd won
one in 1980 so that the guy gave him the fucking right to champ.
That shit at us.
Um,
I dunno when it comes to,
and you always go on that during the day you're taking your shirts off.
It just looks like a big keg party and it almost looks like you don't even give
a fuck.
You know what?
Fuck it.
Let's see the Dodgers and blue jays.
No,
I don't give a shit.
I'm just a,
I absolutely love a playoff baseball.
Um,
I dunno what happens to second,
it becomes October and they throw all those extra microphones and you can just
hear the ball hitting the mic.
It just takes this whole other level of like,
uh,
like the,
the whole mystique of the national pastime just fucking comes to life.
Like I don't for the fucking light from me if they wanted to increase their
ratings,
so keep whatever those playoff microphones are where you can just fucking hear
everything.
You can really hear the sound of the crowd and all of that.
If he just would,
well,
maybe we'd get spoiled.
I don't fucking know.
All I know is it sounds completely different and um,
that adds to the whole thing.
And I've missed every second every fucking pitch because I've been working.
But,
um,
I take my special on Friday and then after that,
I'm going to be a,
I'm going to be just,
I'm going to watch every fucking pitch.
Oh,
I can't wait.
I can't fucking wait.
Oh,
I'm putting my feet,
I'll put my feet up,
but I'm going to keep working out.
Um,
cause I'm down to basically my,
I'm a few pounds so I'm going to be a few pounds over but I'll be fine for the
special and uh,
but I'm going to keep going and get myself into fucking ridiculous shape like it
was last year.
And uh,
the next thing I'm adding to my gym has,
are those fucking Swedish blahs.
So,
uh,
that's my goal.
By the time I'm 50,
I want to be able to do the human flag.
I'm already working on a front lever,
which is really fucking hard man.
Just cause it's just muscles you don't use.
You know,
you ever see somebody do a pull up and then they just go straight out and they
look like they're just there.
Like parallel with the ground is they hold onto the,
to a pull up bar.
MMM.
I've been gradually building up the strength to do that.
I can now hang from the bar with my leg,
might knees tucked up into my chest.
It's all about balance and you have to put,
you actually have to be like pretty much behind the bar.
So like the weight,
especially with me with my big head has to be on one side and then gradually you
start to extend one leg a little bit until you can,
you can hold the whole fucking thing.
And uh,
I dunno,
whatever I have to be working towards shit like that or like workouts just
become,
it's like me trying to write down my jokes.
It just becomes like this unbelievably tedious thing.
All right.
And with that,
let's fucking,
uh,
is there anything else I wanted to say?
Tennessee,
Alabama,
poor Tennessee.
Jesus Christ,
they will fucking roll in there and they just ran into a couple of tough
opponents.
Dude,
Alabama looks like fucking world beaters.
MMM.
Wisconsin.
Ohio state was an amazing game.
I watched that one.
Felt baffle.
Wisconsin man,
they had that fucking game.
Um,
and then Dak Prescott of the,
uh,
Dallas cowboys.
Jesus Christ,
the guy looks like a five year vet.
Um,
but anyways,
I got to tell you this man,
I've been gone almost a week without losing my shit and it feels pretty good.
Like I got to a,
I dunno,
I got to keep doing this type of stuff cause I don't want to be a,
I don't want to be a radio my whole fucking life and I don't know you guys.
Ooh,
it's going to affect your comedy.
Notice it.
Believe me,
I get plenty of left in the reserve tank for and I get on stage.
All right,
let's read some of your questions here for this week.
All right.
All right,
well here's a note from a Andrew.
Uh,
bill got tons of emails from people who watched and loved last week Simpsons
episode as well as this guy who suggest you check it out.
Oh,
this guy didn't know I was in the episode.
Says,
hey bill,
next time you try and to get your ginger ass in shape for 20 minutes,
turn on the newest Simpsons episode and watch it during between your legs during
polities.
There are patriots and Boston references and I think you'd really like it.
I hope to hear you laugh about it in the podcast,
not on the podcast.
Ah,
yes sir.
I was actually always in that episode.
I was the guy who said we want 12 division titles in the last 10 years.
Fair and square.
I was the guy in the,
uh,
in the tunnel and uh,
I think I did one of the new,
so I did one other one.
I didn't record.
I think I was in the other room by that.
Um,
alright.
Westworld.
Not Saying I didn't watch and love the episode,
but I have like fucking add.
I can only sit there for so goddamn long.
Um,
I'm scatterbrained.
Alright.
Westworld.
Hey Billy bought,
I'm fascinated with artificial intelligence.
You mentioned Westworld and a 60 minutes piece last week and I wanted to share
with you this perspective on Ai.
Westworld is the most compelling aspect of Ai is advancement.
MMM.
Westworld is the most,
I think you meant to go Westworld.
He goes,
the most compelling aspect of Ai's is that when it does in fact surpass the
human brain in all aspects and be can and begins to consider self preservation,
it will happen almost completely overnight as far as the public is concerned.
I suggest you watch this short ted talk by Sam Harris.
I actually watched that.
Uh,
we will put up the link.
He also talks about the political implications on the world's stage I II would
China launch an attack if they thought we were dangerously close to losing
control of our technology?
It seems as if,
see this is why,
you know,
I already can't read this guy writes a sentence.
It seems as if though you would need all world leaders as if though,
is that because that grammatically correct.
Oh,
it seems as if comma,
which isn't there though,
you would need all world leaders and tech leaders to focus their efforts on
controlling the AI instead of advancing it further.
Period.
I don't know how to read that sentence.
Uh,
this seems unlikely.
It'd be like jerking off to just the point before completion for the rest of
attorney.
Good luck out there.
Oh yeah.
All the world leaders would,
yeah.
It would want to try to control it.
Yeah.
No.
It's not going to happen.
I don't understand why we're doing it and I don't understand why there has to be
these constant technological improvements.
It's just all based on money.
I mean,
what if it just stopped right here?
Like how fucking great is your life right now?
If you're in a first world country,
you're not the person putting together these devices that makes our lives so
great and in a third world country,
um,
it's,
it's fine.
We should have just fucking would you sit down at the blackjack table rather
than just taking a winnings and just going back to our room would just fucking
sitting here and eventually we're going to work.
It's going to crap out.
We're gonna,
we're gonna,
we're gonna lose it all.
I absolutely believe that 100 fucking percent.
Um,
and I think it is just so fucked up,
weird and bizarre that even if you're not a conspiracy theorist,
what is the fucking purpose of making robots okay?
To this goddamn level?
You know what I mean?
It's just a bunch of fucking Weirdos at the top.
I'm telling you they want to phase out the rest of us and they just want a bunch
of zombies that we'll do whatever the fuck they want him to do and that they can
fucking do whatever the hell they want to them.
Uh,
and then eventually they'll just take them over and they'll fucking kill him.
Or is that like one of the many,
many movies that I've watched about it?
Uh,
anyways,
I,
you know,
I'm a paranoid psycho,
but I think in this instance,
I think it's good to be paranoid.
All right.
Roommates psycho.
Hey there,
you're freckly bastard.
I've been living with the guy for about six months.
We've known each other for about a year.
Everything has been good between us with no issues,
which is weird cause I never have a good experience with roommates.
Well,
if you never have a good experience,
you've got to start looking at yourself,
uh,
either who you're picking or,
um,
maybe you're the asshole,
you know,
maybe you're a cunt.
All right.
Anyways,
over the weekend,
I went out of town to visit family and while I was away,
he got drunk,
went into my room,
tore up a body pillow on my bed.
When I got back,
he had a guilty look on his face,
told me that what happened and then apologize.
Needless to say,
it was fucking awkward and all I could say was that strange behavior and tried
to break the awkwardness by kind of jokingly asking him not to kill me.
Nothing else has been said since regarding the issue.
Uh,
what do you think I should do?
I want to talk to a psychiatrist to see what he thinks,
but I figure you are the next best option.
In other words,
you're too cheap to get a professional opinion.
You're going to ask me,
uh,
first things first,
I get a lock on my bedroom door.
Um,
dude,
if you're literally concerned for your safety,
I would fucking move out.
That's what I would do.
I would basically,
I would get another fucking place without telling this fucking person.
I would move 80% of my shit over there.
I would then fucking tell him in the presence of one of my friends that I was
leaving and uh,
you know,
and I would just,
pay for the last half of the month that I would get the fuck out of that dude.
If you're,
honestly,
if you're going to go see a psychiatrist and you're worried that this guy is
going to do some sort of bodily harm,
two,
I would get the fuck out of there.
I don't care how nice an apartment it is.
I don't give a shit.
If your name's on the fucking lease,
I would just leave the fact that he got drunk and went into your room.
Okay.
And like violently attacked a body pillow.
I mean,
and you're sitting there going like,
did what?
When he was,
he's so drunk that he went in there,
he saw that giant lump and he thought it was me under the pillows and that could
have been,
yeah,
fuck that guy.
And why do you have to feel awkward around him?
Why do you have to break the tension?
Yeah,
you should have been like,
dude,
that's,
that's completely psychotic behavior.
I need you to fucking move out.
You say that after you get rid of all the knives?
Um,
yeah.
I would just,
yeah,
move on the fuck out of there.
All right.
Russia readies for war,
war,
war.
Hey Bill,
did you hear Russia called all its foreign dignitaries back to the homeland?
Uh,
this isn't uncommon before an attack,
but also probably just a scare tactic.
A,
if one day someone came on the news and said Russia threatened to bomb the west
coast,
what would your state of mind be?
A I would be completely chill.
Uh,
would you be like,
Nah,
I never going to happen.
Or would you get in your new green car and hit the road with the lovely Nia and
Cleo in tow?
Um,
no,
no.
If Russia at taxes,
I want to be the first person to get killed.
Yeah.
I don't want to live through that.
I have no desire to live through a fucking world war.
You know what I mean?
It's one thing to actually be in the army.
And you've got a group of pals and shit,
but if you're going to be like the,
you know,
just the old farmer in the town wondering which armies coming up the road next,
I don't eat that Shit,
you know?
Yeah.
It's like that fucking the fat fuck there in North Korea when you said he was
going to shoot a missile at Los Angeles,
it's like,
great.
I hope you shoot it right at my house.
Um,
I like the way the world is right now and what,
whatever.
I was gonna use the word cataclysmic,
but I was worried that I wouldn't say it right.
Whatever fucking major thing happens.
Like I don't want her to survive and I want to be the first person to go and
like a,
you know?
Yeah.
Just be sitting there with my fucking little downloaded music,
listening to it,
and then it's over.
And then when like all the rest of the shit happens.
Yeah.
I don't want to fucking live through it.
Start all over again.
You know,
fucking people getting polio again in the mumps.
Alright.
Cleo,
eating grass.
Ello bill.
I owned a dog for 12 years,
passed away in 2014.
Sorry to hear that.
Sometimes when we were out walking,
it would dive into the bushes and chew on grass.
So my observations,
it usually exhibited this behavior.
If it's de-worming shots,
we're long overdue for month intervals.
Deworming removes the,
uh,
irritating floor that has accumulated in the gut as a result of eating
contaminated food or other nasty stuff your dog may have licked off the floor
while you're not around a dog that is due for deworming,
has poor appetite,
may vomit food,
and sometimes lays laid down awkwardly due to intestinal cramps.
My dog is show none of those symptoms.
My theory at the time was,
since dogs are not herbivores,
herbivores,
I don't know,
ingesting grass was nature's way of getting fibrous roughage into the gut,
like a broom to sweep out the irritating gut.
The end result was that after eating grass,
my dog would later throw up a chunk of undigested food or take a huge dump and
he would be fine for many weeks after that purge.
Yeah,
but my dog eats grass all the fucking time.
I hope my explanation was clear enough.
It may not have been proven scientifically or maybe it has.
You could look it up.
You could look up dog d warming,
but I figured since you've complained about it in more than one podcast and
they'll listeners have written to you about it yet,
I could relate my own experiences with,
with that behavior in a dog.
Nevertheless,
the best solution would be stick to the dog's deworming shuts routine.
I think we do that.
Congratulations on your new Jag.
Thanks for the plug yet.
Um,
yeah,
I always thought it was like some sort of,
I thought they ate grass when they were sick.
Um,
but then she was just kind of doing it all the time.
who knows.
I mean,
who knows what the fuck they put in dog food,
so yeah.
But we always have our up to date on all their stuff.
Um,
all right.
Road rage,
dare billion.
I have a solution to your road rage.
Oh,
okay.
I'm all ears.
It's a tactic I used to keep cool when I'm behind the wheel behind the wheel.
Bear in mind.
This tactic only works if the windows are rolled up.
Whenever you feel the urge to curse.
So yell,
just pretend to do so.
Malvin curse words and whatever else you want to say.
All right,
I'm already out too.
That's just fucking weird.
I'm not doing that and that mouthing.
Fuck you.
You fucking cunt.
Shake your fists in the air and pretend to slam the steering wheel.
Don't damage that Corinthian leather there.
That's hilarious.
Whoever upset you by cutting you off,
we'll see you losing your shit and fear for their safety.
But the joke's on them.
You're just faking it.
You may look like a maniac,
but it's also a lot of fun I guess cause it's so silly.
It takes so much energy and concentration to just pretend to freak out that you
quickly cooled down and possibly forget what you got mad about in the first
place.
I hope this tip helps and congrats on the new car.
There's a lot to be said for strength from the pack,
especially when it comes to European sports sedans.
Best regards.
Um,
yeah.
You know what I do when somebody cuts me off now in public,
I just go la,
you know,
nice move.
You know,
I would've done that.
I try to just,
I try to find the fucking humor.
Um,
I was at,
what I was actually thinking of doing was um,
okay
having a post it or something,
a checklist in my car before I got in the car.
Okay.
And,
um,
even if it's as simple as just drawing a smiley face,
you know,
don't let the consult when underneath it and just,
I dunno,
just
gradually driving down the road.
The big thing is for me is if I'm late,
because I flip out even when I'm not late,
but if I'm fucking weight,
which is my fault,
I start driving like an asshole.
I'm flipping the fuck out.
And um,
but
I'm really going to,
uh,
work on it and I've been great for like the last seven days,
but like an asshole I owe you always hear me on the podcast.
So I go,
did you notice?
Did you notice Nia?
I'm still like a little fucking kid where I need like the attention.
And the fucking approval.
So I'm not doing that anymore.
Uh,
I'm not gonna do it for her fucking approval.
I have to do this,
you know,
because it's the right fucking thing to do.
Rather than trying to get praised for my fucking wife over the whole,
all over the bullshit.
But I am,
I've decided I'm going to,
I'm going to beat this thing because I think I can because I never,
um,
I dunno.
I never,
I never tried
so work on it really.
You know what I mean?
Like I,
uh,
I worked on getting better as a comedian that happened.
I worked on better getting drums that happen.
I worked on getting a pilot's license that happen.
I never worked on my fucking temper.
I just viewed it as like,
well,
that's how I'm wired.
I don't know the fuck you want me to do all that shit.
So,
um,
I would like to be,
you know,
I'm just,
I don't,
I'm done being that guy.
I'm trying,
I can hear all you guys laughing.
Like there's no fucking,
this is like,
it's just not going to happen.
Like,
sometimes I feel like I can beat my temper.
And then other times I feel like I'm,
I'm deciding that I'm going to,
like,
I can't dunk a basketball and it's like,
well,
I've decided that I'm going to learn how to dunk a basketball.
It's just one of the things like,
dude,
if you have,
if you can't jump,
you can't fucking jump.
Um,
sometimes it feels like that.
Like literally I'm trying to like,
I'm going to learn how to sing to your tone deaf.
You can't fucking sing.
You know,
there's just certain things you just weren't born with that gift.
And sometimes I feel like my temporary is like that,
but hopefully,
uh,
hopefully that isn't the case.
All right,
let me read the last couple of advertisements here.
A legal zoom,
attention to detail is key.
When you run a business,
oh,
you mean you can't just wing it there?
Um,
you can't afford to take your eye off the price even for a moment are either one
of those sentences necessary.
Attention to detail is key.
When you run a business,
really you can't afford to take your eye off the price even for a moment.
So don't let things like legal questions become a distraction.
Use Legal Zoom instead.
Legal Zoom was created 15 years ago by the brightest minds and law and
technology as a way for everyday Americans to easily,
affordably and confidently navigate the legal system.
And since legal zoom isn't a law firm,
you never have to worry about an attorney's billable hours piling up and costing
you a fortune.
With legal zoom,
you get no surprise pricing,
no surprises,
pricing,
customer views,
and complete transparency.
Yeah.
Well,
if you're not a law firm,
how the fuck are you going to give me advice on the law?
Uh,
plus you can have the peace of mind.
Oh,
I always say that.
Here it is putting,
plus you have the peace of mine of working with legal zooms network of
independent attorneys available in 48 states who can answer your questions from
start to finish any reasonable flat rate instead of by the hour.
Uh,
so focus your time and energy on growing your business and use legal zoom for
legal stuff.
Legal Zoom,
legal help is here.
Make sure to enter bur bur are in the referral
box@checkouttosaveevenmorelegalzoom.com.
That's legal.
zoom.com.
Always today's date by the way.
October 17th.
Okay,
we're getting close.
Um,
I was just thinking I preordered the new pretenders album.
I think it's coming up soon.
You know,
if none of you guys got a Chrissie Hines last solo album,
Stockholm,
highly recommend that I actually listened to the pretenders album.
What I have to fucking work out.
You know,
some of their early 80 stuff.
And I know you're thinking like,
Bill,
don't you listen to like your fucking guns and roses 80 shit.
Sometimes it's just so fucking early and I'm so old.
Like I need to fucking,
I need something a little more like just mellow,
you know,
it just to try to fucking ease my way into it.
And I've found that,
you know,
those albums have been great for me.
So anyways,
so stamps.com continuing on some small businesses still have still think an
expensive postage.
Meda is the only way to get postage without having to go to the post office,
but they're wrong.
Wrong,
Donald Trump wrong.
Uh,
their stamps.com with stamps.com you can easily print postage for any letter or
package using your,
uh,
your computer and printer.
Uh,
no extra hardware to buy no longterm contracts.
A stamps.com could save you at least 50% compared to a Meta plus.
You could do more with stamps.com you can take a meter,
Niki,
then you can with a meter like send a package like sand package tracking
information to
what the fuck's going on with me here.
Like Sen package tracking information to recipients with one click.
The choice is clear.
stamps.com offers more features at a fraction of the cost.
I had been using stamp gumps stamps.com for years from my shows.
It makes mailing and shipping my uh,
posters.
Really convenient right now.
Sign up for stamps.com and use my last name [inaudible] to get a four week trial
plus a $110 bonus offer,
including postage and a digital scale.
Don't wait.
Go to stamps.com before you do anything else,
click on the microphone at the top of the homepage.
It type it burr.
Alright,
there we go.
I think that is the podcast here for this week.
Um,
scrolling now through my home iTunes.
I don't understand.
You know what?
I can't play any of my fucking music.
It says too many devices have already been cleared to,
uh,
you know,
to listen to iTunes.
So it doesn't let me listen to it anymore.
I can't,
you know,
and I don't remember the passwords.
Have anything else on any other device?
I don't know what other devices they're saying.
Does it mean you know,
my old laptops that are dead?
I got to turn it back on,
find the cord,
plug them in and,
and do what
you know
on and let them listen to fuck and iTunes or does it mean there's too many
devices in the house?
I have no fucking idea as far as I know,
it was just my laptop and my phone.
How can that be too many,
too many devices,
whatever are,
here's the owl alone.
It hasn't come out yet.
The pretenders alone.
Um,
I know it's coming out in like a week or so,
but lately when I've been like lifting,
mmm.
I've been listening to like the whole learning to crawl album,
it's actually fucking great for working out.
Who would have thought?
I always thought you had to have this really aggressive shit.
Um,
I dunno.
I don't know.
I'm all over the fucking place and I can't figure it out.
You know,
I got kicked off of my own fucking Facebook.
Somebody sent me something.
So these fucking pictures,
I don't know if I got phished or whatever.
Now I can't get into my,
I can't get into my,
uh,
my own account.
And he said,
the only way I can turn my account back on is if I send them a picture of
myself.
And I'm just thinking like,
well,
how the fuck do you know what I look like?
So I'm officially done with Facebook.
You know?
Let's see.
Okay.
You don't want,
let me see if I can go on to Facebook right now,
so let's see if my computer will let me my phone.
Whoa.
This is just extra time.
People.
This isn't even the podcast anymore.
This is you.
Just you.
Yeah.
See,
I'm done.
Email or phone.
I don't even recognize.
I fucking hate this shit.
Now what?
I got you.
I got to spend like another 20 hours trying to figure this out.
It's not even worth it to me.
Well,
why do I care if someone fished my fucking account anyways?
What are they going to do with it?
You know what I mean?
You got my,
you have my Facebook account.
There you go.
This is the new me.
The old me would've flipped out.
I still give a shit anymore.
You know what?
You win.
You Win Facebook.
You wind technology.
You fucking cunts.
All right,
that's the podcast for this week.
Thank you for listening.
Thank you to everybody's been coming out to my shows this week and a DC and I'm
really looking forward to putting this thing to bed come.
Um,
this Friday hit the Ryman in Nashville,
Tennessee,
and then old freckles is on fucking vacation for the rest of the year.
CanNot wait.
All right.
Go fuck yourselves and I'll check in on you on a Thursday.